Yo ! C'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouveau coup de Phil',
aux limites de la science avec un paradoxe des plus connus :
le paradoxe du chat de Schrödinger.
Je peux juste faire une blague sur la chatte de Schrödinger ?
Cette expérience, c'est une expérience dite "de pensée".
C'est-à-dire que c'est une expérience qu'on va imaginer,
mais on va souvent pas pouvoir la réaliser.
Pour des raisons, par exemple, de physique ou d'éthique.
(Et d'ailleurs, je suis en train de vous préparer
une petite vidéo sur les expériences de pensée )
Celle-ci nous vient d'Erwin Schrödinger,
un physicien autrichien du début du 20ème siècle,
qui a vachement taffé sur la physique quantique<;
Et, en fait, lui, ce qu'il veut
c'est montrer qu'il y a une grosse différence
entre le monde quantique et notre monde,
qui est le monde macroscopique.
En gros, pour faire simple,
l'idée c'est de prendre une particule atomique,
qui a 50% de chance de se désintégrer
au bout de une heure.
Et, quand elle se désintègre,
elle va relâcher de la radioactivité,
qu'on va ensuite mesurer par un compteur Geiger.
*Accent maghrébin* Comment ça c'est toi qui gère le compteur ?
Il a dit "le compteur je gère".
Si, il a dit "le compteur je gère".
C'est moi qui gère le compteur, c'est tout.
Le compteur va ensuite actionner un marteau,
qui va briser une fiole,
dans laquelle il y a un poison volatile mortel.
Et tout ça, dans une boite
dans laquelle il y a un chat.
C'est un peu tordu.
*Accent allemand* Ach, je ne sais pas comment tuer le chat
dans mon expérience.
Moi j'ai une idée si tu veux...
Mouhahahahahahaha
Ach ach ach ach
Ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'en physique quantique on admet un principe de superposition
En gros, tant qu'on a pas observé ou mesuré,
la désintégration de la particule,
elle est dans les deux états à la fois.
C'est à dire, désintégrée,
donc activation du marteau etc.,
et non-désintégrée.
Or, vu que tout ça ça se passe dans une boite qui est complétement fermée
Le chat n'est pas mort ou vivant comme on pourrait le penser
Il est techniquement mort
et à la fois complètement vivant.
En fait, on peut mettre en perspective cette expérience
avec de grosses questions sur la perception et la réalité.
Parce que, on peut considérer
que c'est l'observateur qui va tuer ou laisser vivre le chat.
Parce que, tant qu'il n'a pas enlevé la boite,
bah le chat il est dans les deux états.
Super poseyyy !
Cette problématique entre perception et réalité
c'est pas la première fois qu'on l'observe.
Et d'ailleurs, ça me rappelle une question assez classique :
"L'arbre qui tombe dans une forêt,
fait-il du bruit si personne ne l'entend tomber ?"
*Voix de Groot* I am Groot !
En gros, ce qui se cache derrière cette question
l'immatérialisme de Berkley
Coup de Phil'-ception
George Berkley c'est un évêque irlandais
et empiriste.
(On va voir ce que c'est dans des prochains Coups de Phil' )
L’immatérialisme c'est une philosophie un peu badass,
qui nie l’existence de la matière.
Dans le plus grand calme.
L’existence de la matière quand même, hein !
La matière mon gars...
En gros, ce qu'il dit,
c'est que les objets que tu vois sont en fait des idées dans ta tête
Alors par exemple si je prend cette pomme,
elle a différentes propriétés,
genre, par exemple, sa forme, sa texture, sa couleur.
Mais ces propriétés n'existent pas de manière indépendante de nous.
Par exemple, sa couleur c'est, en fait, une longueur d'onde
que mon œil va interpréter de cette couleur.
Mais, je ne peux pas imaginer cette pomme sans couleurs.
D'ailleurs, je ne sais même pas ce que c'est
l'absence de couleur.
Bref, vu que ces propriétés
n'existent pas hors de notre esprit,
la matière ne peut pas être une substance extérieure
Du coup, pour que quelque chose existe,
il doit être perçu.
"Esse est percipi"
Donc en gros, sa réponse à la question de l'arbre
c'est: "Non, l'arbre ne fait pas de bruit si personne ne l'entend tomber"
*Voix robot* Appel du docteur Nozman
*Voix électronique* L'arbre en tombant, il va générer une onde de choc
qui va arriver jusqu'à tes tympans.
Ouais je sais
Non, mais cette onde de choc elle va forcement générer du bruit.
Ouais ouais, je sais, je sais
OK
Je sais.
Très bien.
C'était très bien.
Donc voilà, en gros, pour Berkeley,
c'est sa perception qui fait exister les choses.
Il n'y a que deux choses qui existent :
La perception et les idées. Voilà.
Donc, si quelque chose n'est pas dans l'esprit de Berkley
ou si il ne le perçoit pas,
bah ça n'existe pas.
Je pense qu'on est d'accord pour dire que
c'est la philosophie la plus égocentrique qu'on ai vu jusqu’à maintenant.
-Putain mec, hier soir, le concert de Lady Gaga :
Une tuerie mec !
-Oh non... *souffle*
-Tu aurais du venir c'était énorme! - Non, il y a pas eu de concert de Lady Gaga.
-Si je te jure. On y était tous et tout. C'était ouf.
-Non, je ne l'ai pas vu, il n'a pas existé.
-Tu vas pas me refaire ça encore une fois mec !
C'était énorme!
-Non non il n'a pas existé.
-OK, OK...
Alors, si il a pas existé, explique moi comment
j'ai pu te ramener sa prothèse mammaire dédicacée !
Ouais mon gars
- *souffle* Bon, je vais aller prier.
-Ah, tient.
-Merci.
-Pas de problème.
Alors du coup il y a une question qui se pose :
Si il n'y a pas de matière,
par quoi est générée notre perception ?
Bon, vu que c'est un évêque
il c'est pas trop fait chier pour répondre à cette question.
Puisque sa réponse c'est : Dieu.
Donc en gros, sa philosophie, elle a un prérequis,
c'est l'existence de Dieu.
Elle en a même un autre:
c'est qu'en fait, Dieu il est omniscient.
Puisqu'il perçoit tout !
D'ailleurs, du coup, c'est la perception omnisciente de Dieu,
qui fait que les choses nous semblent cohérentes.
Par exemple, si t'es sur une route les yeux fermés
et un casque anti-bruit
de dos et genre il y a quelqu'un qui conduit une caisse les yeux fermés aussi
Et bah il va quand même te percuter.
Pourquoi ? Parce que Dieu perçoit la scène.
Pour vous monter l'étendue du délire,
prenons l'exemple d'une paille qu'on met dans un verre d'eau.
Ce qu'on va voir c'est une paille qui est courbée.
Pourtant, si on la touche, on verra que la paille est droite.
Alors, si on suit le raisonnement de Berkeley,
c'est à dire que Dieu est en train de nous tromper.
Or, ce n'est pas possible.
Dieu il peut pas nous tromper, c'est le bien absolu et tout...
Du coup, Berkeley va plus loin
et dit qu'en fat il y a deux idées de paille.
Il y a l'idée de paille que je touche, qui est droite,
et l'idée de paille que je vois, qui est courbée.
Et même que si t'es avec un pote ça fait quatre idées de paille.
Je vous jure que c'est vrai.
-Tu fais quoi Georges ?
-J'essaye de récupérer mes deux idées de dollar
pour doubler mon billet en fait.
-OK...
-Ouais, un peu relou...
Tu peux partir s'il te plait ?
Déjà avec deux idées j'ai du mal alors avec quatre euh...
Merci
D'ailleurs, petite précision
vu que Dieu perçoit aussi,
en fait, il n'y a pas que deux pailles
il y en a même trois, trois idées de paille,
et l'arbre dans la forêt fait du bruit pour Dieu.
Et cette philosophie, elle va vite nous conduire
comme celle de Descartes dans le Coup de Phil' 6
au Solipsisme
C'est à dire la possibilité que la seule chose
qui puisse être sûre d'exister ou qui existe
c'est moi.
Pour l’anecdote, sachez que Berkeley
représentait à à lui tout seul, à cette époque, en Irlande,
environ 87% de la consommation nationale de cannabis.
Et c'était de la bonne !
En gros, d'habitude notre perception dépend de la réalité
Mais là, pour Berkeley c'est notre perception qui fait la réalité.
Dans un sens, on peut considérer que c'est ce qui se passe avec le chat de Schrödinger.
Car c'est la perception de l'observateur qui définit l'état du chat.
J'espère que la vidéo vous a plu !
N’hésitez pas à checker la description pour plus d'infos,
à me rejoindre sur les réseaux sociaux,
et à partager la vidéo si je vous ai appris un truc
En tous cas moi je vous laisse, j'ai d'autres chats à fouetter !
Je savais que c'était nul de partir sur une blague de merde.
En même temps, c'était une blague qui marchait juste sur la fin,
je pouvais pas faire :
j'ai d'autres chats à fouetter et ensuite
dire "du love et de la peace".
Avoir d'autres chats à fouetter c'est un peu jemenfoutiste comme expression.
Donc, ça n'a pas de sens si j'envoie du love juste derrière quoi.
Bon par contre j'aurais du rebondir sur un jeu de mot positif
sur le fouetté du truc quoi.
En tous cas je vous laisse j'ai d'autres chats à fouetter !
Eh! Ça passe crème, non ? ... Oh putain, c'est chaud.